pendant cette semaine ils sont devenus
associés de l'entreprise éphémère
myriade une cinquantaine de demandeurs
d'emploi ont intégré cette société son
activité rechercher les offres d'emploi
dans le bassin économique du territoire
une organisation autour de six services
est accompagné par trois coachs pour
chaque service il ya un coach un coach
qui va les travées qui va coordonner
l'ensemble du service et donc vous va
confier des missions à des personnes
mais on va vraiment ciblées en fonction
de l'appétence et des compétences des
associés parmi ses missions le service
face à face à sur la prospection
directement auprès des entreprises
ça c'est une carte qui a été déployée en
fait par notre service face à face afin
qu'ils puissent repérer le territoire
sur lequel ils vont prospecter et en
fait ils indiquent par un stabilo taz
les zones qu'ils ont déjà effectué ou
qui sont en cours de prospection
ce jour-là farid et lilia accompagnés
par leur coach krystel sont sur la zone
commerciale de chambourcy une
prospection notamment chez des
concessionnaires automobiles convient de
l'entreprise éphémère mais ryad pour je
vais maintenant de talent et notre
démarche c'est de donner 50 associés
installé sur le secteur de saint quentin
en yvelines et nous venons voir les
entreprises du secteur pour savoir si
vous avez des besoins de personnel
commercialisation de véhicules ateliers
d'entretien et de réparation les
activités de cette société avec des
besoins en main d'oeuvre
moi je trouve que c'est un très bon
concept parce que ça permet aux
personnes d'être dans une démarche
active et puis
et du coup de garder un petit peu le
pied à l'étrier et de voilà de même
développé des compétences au niveau
commercial
les deux associés repartent de cette
entreprise avec deux offres d'emploi au
total le service face à face à
rencontrer plus d'une centaine de
sociétés sur tout le territoire
j'ai une équipe extraordinaire qui ont
le bon discours et qui montrait très
bien la démarche qu'ils ont un très bon
accueil dans les entreprises pour moi le
bilan et il est très positif parce qu'on
avait une grosse grosse équipe de face à
face qui vraiment est sorti tous les
jours en binôme sur les différentes
activités et on fait vraiment tout aux
entreprises qu'on va rencontrer soit un
commerce un petit un grand une pme on
privilégie les entreprises il ya un
accès direct qui facile comme une pme ou
un petit commerce
les grands groupes en général on a plus
de difficultés à notre niveau donc on
passe par un service en interne la
prospection auprès des grands groupes
c'est notamment la mission d'isabelle ce
matin là au bout de la ligne un
représentant de safran résultat elle
obtient le contact d'un collaborateur
des ressources humaines je suis chargé
en fait d'aller chercher des drh des
grandes entreprises sur le bassin de
saint quentin en yvelines entre autres
et de les faire venir de nombreux
représentants d'entreprises ont fait le
déplacement à travers des réunions
appelé open job ils viennent proposer
des offres d'emploi c'est notamment le
cas de la sncf
j'ai des offres de d'aiguilleur non
qu'opérateur et ensuite des offres de
technicien supérieur au niveau bac + 2
bac + 3 pour travailler dans les postes
d'aiguillage assurer la sécurité des
circulations et la régularité des trains
au total des associés ont répertorié
près de 650 offres d'emplois
l'entreprise éphémère l'occasion aussi
de s'entraîner pour trouver un emploi
entretien d'embauché fictif pour etienne
et laurence deux associés de
l'entreprise éphémère myriade de saint
quentin en yvelines
amira where any la coach observe pour
les conseiller sur les points à
améliorer
voilà une activité quotidienne pour les
membres de l'entreprise éphémère une
personne va jouer le rôle du candidat ou
là il va s'entraîner en faisant son
pitch et faire sa simulation
d'entretiens avec des questions qui lui
sont posées
après il ya une personne qui va jouer le
rôle du recruteur est comme ça il va
donc lancer l'entretien de recrutement
et poser les questions
c'est un très bon exercice pour moi
d'être du côté recruteur avec une des
coachs et de pouvoir aider mais mes
collègues à se positionner sur sur leur
poste et à voir ce qui va ce qui va
moins bien et étendre avec des
améliorations pour les aider etienne lui
joue le rôle du candidat
dans quelques jours il a un entretien
d'embauché dans une entreprise à
guyancourt
à la fin de l'expérience onze membres de
l'entreprise éphémère ont retrouvé un
emploi
seize sont dans un processus de
recrutement